like long before we kind of had these
digital tools to make it all so seamless
and easy and remote work just completely
accelerates it i've been a digital nomad
since 2013. a digital nomad is
essentially a person who remote works
and travels at the same time the more
kind of international experiences you
have the more you begin to question the
fundamentals in the society that you
come from there are so many people now
who are able to kind of make the same
living that they would make in a sort of
traditional in-person job through the
internet instead realizing that you
don't kind of have to play by the same
rules as people did in the past is to
kind of think about what you can do with
these newfound powers
hey friends welcome back to deep dive if
you're new here my name is ali and each
week it is my job to sit down with
entrepreneurs authors creators and other
inspiring people and we talk about the
journeys of how they got there and these
strategies and tools that we can apply
to help live our best lives in this
episode i sit down with my friend lauren
rozavi who is the author of a really
really really good new book called
global natives which is all about
digital nomads when we put out our
survey for listeners at the end of the
last season of the episode of the
podcast loads of you asked for an
episode about how to become a digital
nomad and lauren is like the world
expert on the topic having done it since
like 2013 having written a book about it
having interviewed everyone who is like
big in the digital nomad scene and we
talk a lot about practical actionable
tips on how you can also become a
digital nomad we talk about a little bit
of the history behind the movement how
tim ferriss is the four-hour workweek
changed the game in terms of making the
movement more accessible some of the
like the ethical implications around
being a digital nomad and what it's like
to go to a kind of country where the
cost of living is really low and
potentially kind of quite exploit that
country uh by working from there and we
talk a little bit about lauren's mission
to try and build a country on the
internet and how that is hopefully
trying to solve loads of issues
associated with visas and immigration
and kind of the idea of the nation state
and a bunch of really cool topics around
this idea of the future of work and how
it sort of interacts with technology and
this digital nomadic stuff i will put
links to lauren's book down in the video
description so you can check that out if
you like but i hope you enjoy this
conversation between me and lauren
rosabi we've known each other for a
while now and we met on the internet
which has been like super cool and
interesting and i'm just saying to
gordon just now that you're probably the
person who's like the internet friend
who's most impacted my life because
thanks to the connection that we made on
twitter uh you introduced me to kate who
is both of our book agents he introduced
me to rachel who is now both of our book
book editors and the book has become so
much better with the edition of kate and
rachel's influence across all fronts
than it would have been and yours as
well so firstly massive thank you for
that um no worries i wanted to talk to
you about like this idea of being a
digital nomad because you're a digital
nomad
ish if you maybe identify with that term
i kind of first discovered the term in
2017 when i read the four hour work week
by tim ferriss 2017 no not 2017. or like
2011 uh at the age of 17. when i wrote
the four hour work week by tim ferriss
and i've often talked about on the
channel about how that's the book that's
most impacted my life because it put me
on this trajectory of like oh crap you
can build a business you can have
streams of passive income you could
potentially live anywhere in the world
all that kind of stuff
and you've just written a book
which explores like the history of
digital nomadism and some of the issues
with it um
where where do we begin with the
discussion about like what's the deal
with digital nomads and why are people
so interested in becoming one and then i
guess how do people become one i think
those are the three kind of areas we
want to talk about that was a very like
rambling initial question go for it no
worries
so i guess probably the best place to
begin is just a straightforward
definition of digital nomads
and
a digital nomad is essentially a person
who remote works and travels at the same
time
and that can play out really differently
depending on who you are and where you
want to spend time um and kind of what
life stage you're at i guess
i've been a digital nomad since uh 2013
but i only learnt the term in 2015. we
can get a little bit more into that and
the kind of story there if you'd like
but um for me it kind of means that i
spend three to six months per year here
in the uk and then i spend six to nine
months per year elsewhere traveling
around
and i try and go back to the same places
say amsterdam and malaysia are places
that i really like to kind of go and
spend time and keep going back to
and i've become really kind of local in
those places so in the same way that i
could walk around my hometown here in
the uk and kind of know where everything
is and know where to go get something
printed or buy stationery or buy clothes
or whatever i know how to do that in a
bunch of different places um and so
i guess the thing that i find most
interesting about digital nomads is
the way they kind of represent how the
internet has changed our relationship
with place so the fact that you can
remote work the fact that you and i can
become friends on the internet just
completely changes like what's possible
for an individual life um and i think
that's one of the most interesting kind
of um
things to keep an eye on now that we're
in a world of remote work now that
that's completely normalized yeah um so
i guess when you started doing it this
was i guess pandemic has really
accelerated the whole remote remote work
stuff
what was like how how did people do the
digital nomad thing back in the day did
it have to be that you were sort of some
sort of internet entrepreneur selling
supplements online or were there other
kind of routes that people took to do
this sort of traveling around the world
while working from a laptop kind of
lifestyle
yeah definitely there are a few
different ways so i guess number one um
is teaching english abroad um before the
digital was quite so prominent in
digital nomad when it was kind of more
about kind of traveling and working at
the same time but not necessarily
remotely english teaching was like a
really big kind of source of employment
for people so i know folks i'm almost
30. i think i'll be 30 by the time this
uh this comes out um but i know folks
who are about 10 years my senior who
started traveling long before the
internet was kind of enabling uh remote
work on on a large scale um so that's
definitely one of the entry points for
me personally i worked as a journalist
so i worked as a foreign reporter i kind
of just traveled from place to place for
a few years
just picking up stories along the way
and i don't know i uh i did a lot of
work for the guardian over a number of
years and i remember a very uh senior
editor there like a dude who'd been
there for like 20 or 30 years telling me
about how
uh back in the day when he started as a
journalist um filing your copy so like
submitting your article involved like
picking up the phone and literally like
talking your article to a person in the
office on the other end so if you're a
foreign reporter and you're like
indonesia in indonesia or somewhere you
are literally like phoning up on a
crackly phone line and
reciting a thousand words and that's how
you kind of created your story so i
guess one of the things that i go into
in the book that i find really
fascinating are the ways in which
in the creative industries people have
been able to work from anywhere like
long before the internet like long
before we kind of had these digital
tools to make it all so seamless and
easy
um
and remote work just completely
accelerates it so
there are so many people now who are
able to kind of make uh the same living
that they would make in a sort of
traditional in-person job through the
internet instead
and i think like the kind of natural
i guess the kind of natural reaction to
um
realizing that you don't kind of have to
play by the same rules as people did in
the past is to kind of think about what
you can do with these newfound powers
and so a lot of people now as remote
workers are going okay so i could live
in london and this is what my rent would
be or i could go live in malaysia or i
could go live somewhere in africa and
this is what my rent would be um and so
it's just kind of a
shuffling reshuffling of kind of like
what's possible for people yeah like so
that was one of the things that i most
um kind of that blew my mind when i
first read the four-hour workweek that
um kind of his his argument is broadly
um
you know everyone wants to be rich but
the reason they want to be rich is not
because of the money but it's because of
the lifestyle that being rich allegedly
affords
and did you know you can have that same
lifestyle for like a tenth of the price
in thailand versus in the uk or in the
us or in new york or in london places
like that
and therefore you need a tenth of the
amount of money to live therefore if you
build a business that does and is
automated and passive income and
outsourcing and all of those things that
we're gonna that we're gonna touch upon
it will then you know you'll be able to
live like a proverbial king for a
fraction of the cost of living in a
normal house in in london uh is the kind
of
economic factor like the main thing that
you find people
move people become digital nomads for or
is it more like the lifestyle aspect
like it seems cool like traveling the
world and like working from your laptop
and stuff there's something about it
that seems
quite romantic in a way but i guess you
know pros and cons to every lifestyle so
i think affordability is a really big
deal like in the world
uh the kind of major cities where
previously you could access work
opportunities have become really really
unaffordable for the vast majority of
people you know you can be working at a
big tech company earning a really good
salary
and it's still really hard to buy a
property in london and i think that that
has definitely been a factor
in people deciding to become digital
nomads you know we kind of listen to our
parents and their kind of perception
that generation's perception of like
what success looks like and what a good
a good life looks like in terms of being
responsible in terms of kind of
earning the right amount and kind of
buying a house and having kids or
whatever it might be
but i think the kind of economic
situation that a lot of digital nomads
have found themselves in is like but i
could not work for 40 years in an office
to then kind of go and enjoy my life at
the end of my life when i'm retired
instead i could actually kind of make
things work now and be able to kind of
um go to places where my money stretches
further where i'm able to kind of have a
better lifestyle and there aren't these
kind of i guess quite traditional
pressures of like you should buy a house
you should settle down and so i think
that's definitely a big one like i talk
about that quite a bit in the book uh
this kind of like lack of affordability
being a really big reason why people
explore the nomad lifestyle and kind of
go for it
um but for me personally uh it goes a
bit beyond that uh because
i come from a very sort of international
family my dad is a refugee from iran to
the uk in the 1980s
he's the youngest of eight children and
all eight of those children went to
different places in the world so like
dubai australia the us germany and so
when i was growing up i
traveled to lots of different
places and kind of visited family
and got kind of a bit local in these
different places kind of going back
there every year or every couple of
years to visit family
and with my cousins we were really bad
at keeping in touch in between um kind
of seeing one another so we would just
kind of pick up our relationships again
uh a year later or two years later uh
like we were best friends and so i think
these were really formative experiences
for me because it kind of made me look
at the world from a really young age as
a very global place
and maybe it's relevant to note as well
that coming from an iranian family like
a kind of diaspora family it wasn't just
kind of going to germany and
experiencing german culture it was kind
of going to germany but actually being
in an apartment and experiencing iranian
culture persian culture this kind of
little bubble of it within germany but
these kind of different cultural
experiences just meant that when i kind
of like left school um
i was like oh like i am not just going
to live in one place like i'm going to
spend time in different places i have
relationships that are completely
cross-border um and so for me like as i
said before like i i didn't know like
what a digital nomad was until 2015 but
i started living as a digital nomad uh
in 2013 and sort of traveling around
like this so for me it was just kind of
instinct of feeling like quite a global
citizen so why wouldn't i kind of live
my life in this way right so in this
conversation we talked a lot about the
four hour work week by tim ferriss which
was the the seminal book that really
kind of brought the whole nomad movement
onto the scene if you would like to get
an accelerated summary of the insights
from the four-hour workweek then you can
check out the summary they've got over
at short form who are very kindly
sponsoring this episode short form is by
far and away the single best service i
have ever found for summarizing
non-fiction books it's absolutely sick
it's way more than just a book summary
they do have one page summaries of all
the key points in the book but then they
also have chapter by chapter summaries
and they even have like interactive
exercise-y bits in between those chapter
by chapter summary so you can really
engage with the ideas in the book short
form is also great because what they do
is that they bring in ideas from other
books as well so if for example tim
ferriss has said something particularly
controversial in the book and there is
evidence that that is actually not true
or that there's more sides to the story
or there's a bit of nuance they will
include a little short form note within
the summary itself and say hey if you
look at the book drive by daniel pink
you'll find that daniel pink argues for
the exact opposite viewpoint so you
might want to do that you know with
reading on fiction it's very easy to get
into that mindset where you just take
everything the author says as gospel
truth but the nice thing about short
form is that they will flag up when
controversial issues are being discussed
and then you can kind of get a little
bit more of a balanced viewpoint as well
it's genuinely a really really really
good service i've been using it for like
two years now and anytime i get a book
recommendation i tend to look it up on
short form first if it's available as a
book summary and every year they're
adding more and more and more but if
it's available as a book summary i'll
usually read that first and then if i
enjoy the summary and i think oh it
would be worthwhile reading the book
then i read the book itself it's also
really good for books i've read like
i've read this multiple times since like
the age of 17 up until the age of 28 now
it's useful to revisit the main points
so kind of there's two ways i revisit
points from books i've read number one
is rereading my kindle highlights
because i usually read these on kindle
but the second way is to look at the
short form summary and see oh hello is
there something interesting i've missed
over here anyway if any of that sounds
up your street and you also want to get
the best book summaries more than just
book summaries in the world then head
over to short form dot com forward slash
deep dive and with that link you will
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much short
form for being a sponsor of this episode
for let's say someone my age i you know
27
have a job
where that you know currently is kind of
based in london but i've kind of always
thought oh this digital nomad stuff
would be cool i imagine there's a lot of
people watching or listening to this who
are like oh that that seems cool like
yeah hell yeah i'd love to travel the
world and work for my laptop
yeah would you would you recommend it i
definitely would recommend it i'd
recommend it to you in particular i'm
always going on at you about this my
ally go traveling
uh and i think the reason that i'd
recommend it is that
as a digital nomad you kind of go
through this accelerated personal growth
kind of uh experience because
i guess you can think of it as like um
we're all kind of born into these little
boxes that we call countries right and
from a really young age we kind of have
propaganda thrown at us like the uk is
the best country in the world this is so
great like look at all these things we
did in history and look at all the
wonderful kind of like buildings we have
uh and actually when you start to travel
and you start to spend time in different
places kind of understand the politics
kind of understand like how a place
works
a lot of that kind of propaganda i guess
uh does get broken down so you start to
go oh okay so like britain kind of
prides itself on that but the
netherlands is so much better at this
and you go to all of these different
places and even if they are places that
aren't very developed yet you know very
much in the emerging economies kind of a
bracket
actually they have things that they
really excel at and they have things
that um
are really unique about that place so i
think for me it's been really really um
sort of inspiring and exciting to step
outside of that kind of national
understanding and instead begin to kind
of look at the world as a place of like
incredible diversity and incredible kind
of brilliance in different ways
and i think that that has really fed my
own personal growth like i've had so
much more time to think and reflect and
think about things that i think a lot of
other people take for granted i like the
kind of status quo of like no the
is getting a job
going through like some corporate ranks
is buying a house is finding somebody to
marry is finding uh is having children
with that person um i think the yeah the
more kind of international experiences
you have the more you begin to question
the fundamentals in the society that you
come from
so people often say that traveling
broadens your horizons but you know i've
been on holiday to various places for up
to a week at a time and i feel like my
horizons have not broadened at all uh is
there something special about going for
an extended period of time and i guess
how do you
because i can imagine myself like even
if i were living in amsterdam for three
months
living in a nice apartment slash hotel
going to the same coffee shop every day
going to the gym i'd basically
transplant the life i have in london and
just put it in a different country and
not necessarily like interact with the
locals um
is that like a concern sometimes or
whatever so i think it's definitely a
concern in general like i think there's
a real risk that digital nomads kind of
create like parallel social circles so a
good example of this is is bali uh which
is the the place where i learnt uh what
a digital nomad was uh back in like
2015. but in bali uh
it's really a place that has uh exploded
and kind of become known as like the
nomad capital of the world
um but it can be really problematic if
you have like a lot of nomads in one
location and actually they are just
essentially living their own kind of
bubble life
without actually interacting with local
people or the local culture beyond maybe
having like a waitress or whatever in
that kind of respect and i do think that
that is problematic but i also think
there's a lot of really great work going
on to kind of break down those barriers
and kind of integrate people more one of
the really key kind of challenges with
being a nomad over the past 10 years has
been that you're sort of operating and
living in this gray area so
what you are doing
generally is moving from place to place
on tourist visas
and
that
is
essentially it's like when you when you
move around the world on tourist visas
you're sometimes allowed to conduct
business as well so if you're a
freelancer like you might be like okay
i'm gonna go conduct business in
singapore and that's kind of what's
brought me here
um but in general you're not allowed to
work on those visas but remote works a
weird one yeah there's a lot of those
kind of um
policies that are designed to kind of
protect local populations um from people
essentially coming to take jobs
are not really taking into account what
remote work is because when you're a
remote worker you are in an economy and
you are spending there like you're
spending money on accommodation and gym
and coffee or whatever
um and actually that creates a lot of
kind of local opportunities and that can
be really good in the same way that
tourists coming to a place can be good
because there's more money kind of
circulating in that local economy people
can start a coffee shop because they
know there are a bunch of like nomads
there who they they can kind of have as
the target market
um so yeah i think that
it's there are a lot of benefits to
kind of having uh digital nomads or
remote workers in a place and a lot of
the policy at the moment the legislation
just doesn't really have any way of
distinguishing between like i'm gonna
come here and i'm gonna get a job as a
cleaner and that means a local person
can't have that job as a cleaner or i'm
going to come here and work on my laptop
and just spend my money in your economy
yeah um so that's a i think a really
kind of um big
uh issue
coming back to like your point there
about like you know if you kind of
transplant your life to a different
place i kind of think this is the key
difference between tourism if you if
you're a tourist you kind of go
somewhere for a week right and you
probably like bring your own shampoo and
it probably lasts you for that week and
i know that's a really small thing but
it's kind of like it's got my kind of
little travel cleanser shampoo
conditioner the whole shebang it's all
it's all in the wash bag right so you
take that you go for a week you come
back you probably haven't had to buy
anything unless you forgot your
toothpaste and then you go to the corner
shop and you buy some toothpaste and
you're set
when you go somewhere for like one to
three months you're kind of forced to
localize a bit more because you're gonna
have needs in that period of time which
uh are not gonna be covered by the
what's in your suitcase and also because
you're there for a longer period of time
so like when we travel we automatically
go it's like oh you know i want to print
this thing but it's like 50 pages so
maybe i'll just wait until next week
when i'm like back at my home base with
my own printer
if you're a digital nomad and you're
kind of localized to a place it's like
okay well i'm not going to wait three
months to print the 50 page document i
want to print so i'm going to go seek
out a local print shop
and so you just kind of
interact with the place in a very
different way um another example is like
uh you know if you're going somewhere
for a week and you're staying in a hotel
uh you're probably gonna have the hotel
cleaners come in every day and sort out
your room if you're staying in an airbnb
for three months you need to figure out
where the trash goes how to divide up
the trash like kind of like how how to
be local in this place
um and so yeah i think it's quite a
different dynamic like tourists
and
so tourists kind of go to a place and
they kind of use it for a week or a
weekend
i think nomads really go to a place and
they kind of integrate for a period of
time and maybe they stay for one to
three months at first and then maybe the
following year they come back for
another one to three months if they like
that destination okay so um a few things
that we've touched on so far so you
mentioned bali 2015 was when you heard
the term digital nomad what was the what
was the story behind that
okay so spoiler alert because uh i think
this opens the whole book um but
essentially i was working as a
journalist for the guardian newspaper
covering business and tech
and
a guy called casey reached out to me and
he was like
so
i've i've got this startup and we are
organizing trips for remote workers
he was like would you like to come out
to bali and see what we're doing and i
was like sick yeah i'll come to bali why
not
my uh my partner also had like spent a
lot of time in bali and he was like yeah
like you should definitely go like it's
uh it's a really cool place there's kind
of a lot going on there
uh so i flew out to bali
did this story for the guardian that was
about this startup my friend casey
startup hacker paradise which is still
going and like a little plug
you can book these kind of group trips
uh if you want to kind of test out the
digital nomad lifestyle so hacker
paradise is still one of those companies
that's organizing those trips so it
basically means instead of going like
okay i'm gonna book an airbnb for 30
nights and go and see what
sort of what this is like you can
instead kind of book an experience for
30 days and you're there with a bunch of
other nomads like a bunch of other
people who are kind of experimenting
with the lifestyle yeah there's a whole
bunch of companies that do it now but
hacker paradise was uh i think the first
like i was certainly the first person to
kind of report on this trend uh for the
guardian back in 2015.
um but yeah i went out there and i met
these guys and casey
told me about the startup told me about
what they were doing and said um
you know uh this is
this is kind of uh we think this is
going to be a big trend we think that
like more people are going to do this uh
and so i was like wow like
i've been living like this as in like
i've been living kind of working from a
laptop from one suitcase for a couple of
years like what is the name for this and
i asked casey that question directly he
said digital nomad that's what people
call us
and so that's when i kind of learned
this language of like digital nomads um
i don't think it actually features in
that original guardian story like the
language it wasn't particularly like
important for the business story that i
was kind of covering at the time
um but yeah i realized i'd been living
that way for a couple of years that that
kind of described me um and from there i
guess that was how many years ago now
like six seven years ago
from there i kept in touch with all of
those guys who i met in bali and i
continued to kind of travel as a nomad
and made a bit more effort to try and
like socialize with other people and
kind of understand how other people were
living the lifestyle
um and now i work full-time on uh kind
of digital nomad infrastructure which
i'm sure we'll get into in a bit yes
definitely we'll get into that
in a in a bit just to put a little peg
in that um you are
working for a company that's trying to
build a country on the internet that is
correct which is interesting uh but
we'll definitely talk about that in in a
little in a little while uh is
being a digital nomad lonely
i think being a digital nomad can be
lonely it's not for me personally
because i'm married to a digital nomad
so um my my partner my husband jesse and
i have been traveling together um
since 2014. so we met in 2013. i was
already kind of doing a lot of traveling
and we just kind of met and have built a
relationship on the road so i'm very
rarely lonely because he's a really
awesome dude so i just get to hang out
with like my best friend all the time
um and i also think that
one of the things that i've done in my
time is a digital nomad that i see other
people having not done and they tend to
complain about loneliness more than i do
is
i try and arrange my trips around going
to see people in different places so a
good example of this is i'm going to
spend a couple of months in the u.s this
summer and i'm going to go and i'm going
to see rachel our book editor and i'm
also going to visit some safety wing
colleagues and people that i work with
and safety wing also has like a house in
san francisco so i'm going to kind of go
stay there and hang out with uh with the
team who are based there so
i try and just organize trips so that
actually i am going to visit someone on
the ground um and if you're if you do it
like that you kind of can uh connect
with their social network on the ground
so that makes for a much sort of softer
landing maybe another good example
actually is i spent some time in el
salvador at the beginning of this year
and my friend john had moved from new
york to el salvador maybe six or eight
months before and he had a really really
kind of wide social circle there so as
soon as we arrived like first night it's
like let's go out for dinner and drinks
table full of eight people
and suddenly you're kind of making new
friends wherever you go in that respect
um
i do think that the digital nomad kind
of lifestyle can be lonely though if you
are
single
new to the lifestyle
and you're not going to visit people
essentially so then it becomes kind of
like you are transplant transplanting
your life from wherever you were before
and kind of moving from place to place
and maybe having amazing experiences but
just at the end of the day not really
having anyone to to kind of share that
with
um
so yeah i think the communities like
hacker paradise who mentioned before i
think they're a really good way to kind
of overcome some of that loneliness um i
also think that a lot of people feel
like they have to either be a digital
nomad or not a digital nomad like a
nomad or a settler like they have to
either choose the path
of being only in one place and building
a life there or they have to choose a
life on the road
whereas
i think it's much more mixed than that
you kind of find the right balance for
you so like do you want a home base at
all i have colleagues who have no home
base so they don't have a home anywhere
they don't actually stay anywhere long
enough to to kind of like uh establish a
home base
um and that's like one way to do it but
then there are also ways to do it where
you're just kind of like genuinely
building like a borderless life so maybe
um an example of this is uh my husband
and i like would like to get properties
in the netherlands and malaysia and so
it's not so much that we want to travel
like 365 days per year but it's more
like we want to move between a few
different locations and actually kind of
have home bases there which you can kind
of monetize on airbnb or kind of ways
like that when you're not using them
okay so this i feel like this is the
problem that i have right now where i'm
thinking in my in my mind it's like all
or nothing that i have to be traveling
or i have to be in london and
in my in my mind i'm also kind of
thinking you know like right now i'm
renting a place in in central london
it's pretty expensive and so like the
the sunk cost of that you know plays in
my mind where i think oh i mean i could
go
traveling and go to a cool place for a
month but then i'm kind of quote
throwing money down the drain on rent in
this in this place uh i've been thinking
about like potentially looking to try
and buy a flat in central london or
somewhere in london to use as this home
base but i didn't quite clog that you
could kind of airbnb it out for like
short small periods of time um yeah
what's what sort of setup would you
recommend for me given
the context
ah
okay so
i mean it depends where you want to
spend time right so like are there
particular places in the world that you
visited and you were like this place is
sick i want to spend more time here yeah
a few i think uh tokyo has been pretty
sick i think hoi an in vietnam was
pretty sick i've got family in karachi
so i'd like to kind of spend some time
there um in in pakistan every now and
then
um but i'm still very much thinking that
i don't really know
the idea of traveling and living
someplace for one to three months seems
cool
but i've never done it to know what it
would actually be like
so i guess my recommendation to get kind
of practical on it is i try not to
remote work anywhere that i haven't
spent a week that's more of a holiday
first and the reason for that is because
if you are trying to maintain like a
regular working pattern
whilst traveling from place to place and
you find that you are moving like every
month and every time you arrive there's
a problem that you didn't expect eg you
can't get a sim card the wi-fi at your
airbnb is rubbish like these kind of
practical issues that can become like
really really draining um and so
it can be good to kind of do a recce
like do a test run so you go somewhere
for a week and one you see if you like
it and two you see what kind of
practical problems you come up against
um
you know
bad wi-fi is like a really big one in
the in the minds of nomads but there's
also like a lack of good co-working
space uh accommodation that doesn't look
like the pictures so you end up moving
as soon as you arrive there's kind of a
lot of friction points there
um and so i find it really good to go
and visit for a week kind of low
pressure you don't have a lot of work to
do or anything you're just there to kind
of experience the place as a kind of
test run to then go back for one to
three months later um and so i guess my
my ali abdel
kind of recommendation here would be for
you to kind of explore some places for a
week on that basis of like could i work
here what kind of obstacles do i think i
would encounter and then plan a trip
that's a bit a longer term it can be
good as well to kind of plan one to
three months in a place when there's
something going on so if there's like
halfway through your three-month trip
there's like a big conference going on
and you know that five friends are going
to be in that place for that conference
it can be a nice way to kind of like
organize your time nice okay that sounds
good um one thing that you mentioned is
that it's way easier to make friends if
you are going to see pre-existing
friends but we have a bit of a sort of
chicken and egg situation is that if you
don't know anyone in the place that
you're visiting then you it's hard to
kind of get that social network off the
ground
um i've got a few friends who we've
spoken spoken to about this like digital
nomadi type life who are like kind of
working in a traditional lore consulting
such a banking job here in london the
only people they know other people from
university slash people working in that
job and to them the thought of like
making friends on the internet just
seems a bit bizarre and to them like
twitter is this thing that gets that
gives them the news and like incendiary
things that donald trump has well
tweeted in the past
uh
what does the pro i guess what i'm
asking is what is the process of making
friends around the world look like these
days um yeah
okay so maybe a good place to start with
this is is like where do you actually
start if you literally are someone who
has the flexibility to
try out the nomad lifestyle um
what what does it look like to kind of
like meet like where do you go in order
to kind of like meet people on the
ground and i think number one is
co-working spaces so co-working spaces
can be a really really good source of um
social connections so
uh as well as physically like working in
the same space as others maybe going to
get a coffee and ending up chatting to
someone that kind of thing um there are
also a lot of like networking events or
just general events like whether it's
like morning yoga or kind of like salsa
classes or things like that yeah like
they tend to be like community hubs so i
guess in the same way that if you were
to move to a new city as a remote worker
as in to relocate let's say from london
to paris you would be like okay how am i
going to make new friends here
maybe and work i still think it's a
really big source of like new friends um
so yeah that would be number one it's
like co-working spaces super super
useful really great resources some folks
kind of say like oh i don't want to pay
for a co-working space i'd rather just
get accommodation with a table but it's
like okay but then you will be lonely
because you have to optimize for a whole
bunch of different things as a nomad not
just like affordability or whatever so i
think there are sort of different
benefits at different times
another thing i'd say is that like being
part of a remote team is a really good
way to have international connections so
at safety wing we have i think it's 120
employees across 70 countries
so if i had just joined our team
and i wanted to to kind of travel around
the world and not get too lonely i feel
like it's uh really easy to just be like
okay so who do i speak to a lot at work
shall i see if i can go and kind of
visit them
and not necessarily like staying in
their house although some people very
kindly do offer that and that can be
kind of a nice intimate
way to get to know a place and to kind
of be closer with a colleague but
literally just going to the same city
and so it's like okay great so
i'm gonna stay for three months and once
a week i'm going to have in fact
london's a good example it's like okay
i'm going to spend three months in
london and once a week i'm going to have
lunch with ali and that's kind of your
starting point
to then kind of build out more of a
social network okay yeah so i guess it
doesn't it doesn't seem as hard as i've
got i come kind of thinking in my head
because like yeah if i were to move to
i don't know a new city i didn't know
anyone i would do those things and be
like all right i need to actively take
charge of my own social life you know
set up the the hinge profile or whatever
look on meetup.com to see what's going
on look at anything anything local join
a local gym join local badminton club
all of all of the usual things that a
normal person would do to get to know
people i guess also applies to the
the digital nomad totally and maybe
actually to give some other examples um
from my partner and is life like um
jessie uh likes to play football so
he will uh there's an app i can't
remember what it's called um but there
is a football app where you can
basically like sign up and be like i'm
in this city and i want to do like five
aside um and then a bunch of other
people kind of sign up too and then you
go and you play football together and
say he's made like a bunch of friends
around the world through that and it's
always kind of fun because um i remember
like once he uh did it in malaysia and
like he was wearing like a norwich city
that's like our hometown he's wearing
like a norwich city shirt and he went
and it was like people from literally
like four or five different countries um
and so again it's kind of like i guess
tapping into kind of a global network
like people in different places and i
think in malaysia he met quite a few
expats who were new and so it's the same
kind of principle it's like you're in a
place you want to meet people what do
you like to do um and i guess the answer
is kind of different for everyone like
i'm really bad at football so i don't
participate in the football part but
kind of have other ways of like writing
like writing groups like writing salons
is another way that i really like to
meet people although a lot of the world
is very lacking on that front the uk has
a really good writing culture that's
something i've learned from my travels
oh i should try and look up some writer
sounds
that'll be fun what does the company do
like what's what's the vision like
what's what's going on here
i work for a company called safety wing
and our kind of core mission is to build
a global social safety net and basically
what that means is making things like
health insurance income protection
insurance and pensions
available not based on like your
national citizenship but instead as like
an opt-in kind of membership or
subscription um so in a really practical
sense um we sell borderless health
insurance that's our main product at the
moment for both uh individual digital
nomads and for remote teams
and it basically means like if you ali
have travel insurance right yup if you
break your leg while you're overseas you
then get uh sent back to the uk as in
they'll like do emergency stuff on you
but then they're going to sort of like
airlift you back to the uk
your citizenship home kind of country
and they're going to sort you out there
with our product
you can seek healthcare on the ground
wherever you are
so
if you think conceptually that digital
nomads are potentially people who don't
have a home country or a home base
uh this means that essentially the
product is designed around like their
needs to be able to if you're in mexico
and you have a healthcare problem you
need to go and see a gp essentially you
can go and do that there
um and so that's like the first kind of
product um that we have and then we're
also working on these other things that
i mentioned so like borderless pensions
right now if you have a pension in the
uk and then you move to the netherlands
for two years you then end up with two
pensions that kind of don't interact
with one another and so again trying to
make as much of this as possible uh
borderless
my role at the company is as director of
special projects and my main project is
called plumia
and it's essentially working on the
vision for the internet country that we
want to build from these services and so
what do you what do you mean by internet
country
so the the vision is to essentially like
recreate uh nation-state infrastructure
on the internet
on a global level
so in a really practical sense there's a
kind of safety wing products those are
being worked on
my part of the company is very focused
on global mobility so essentially visas
and passports and such
so our 10-year roadmap
is aiming to create a fully functional
global passport that is issued uh based
on a person's kind of income and
profession as opposed to the sort of
coincidence of where they were born
that's like what the kind of mission
that i'm working on
and before we get to the passport part
um we're planning to essentially create
new mobility tools uh that sort of pave
the way to a passport okay like visas
and things or yeah so one of the things
that we're working on is called the
nomad border paths and it's essentially
an
instrument that allows you to
apply for
a nomad visa in one country but then get
access to like 20 countries and so the
idea being that this kind of visa in the
future will be issued for let's say 10
years and will allow you to
go and spend three months one month
three months kind of whatever the
um specifics kind of end up being but to
go and very legitimately kind of like
work as a nomad in that country
and have kind of a dialogue and shared
understanding with the government
because at the moment uh there are a lot
of issues i think with the first kind of
like round of nomad visas that have has
come out in response to the pandemic
okay
all right so
i'm just going to try and sort of get my
head around what's what's going on here
and you can tell me where i'm missing
things or where we're going to add stuff
so i recently read uh the sovereign
individual which i'm sure you're
familiar with and as part of like this
tech bro book club thing that i was part
of and it was it was interesting it took
talked about how
you know the idea of nation states is a
bit of like an a sort of uh a relic from
a bygone era
and
really before reading this book i i i
just like never heard the term nation
state before
because and then after reading it i i
now see it propping up a lot and it's
just sort of we take for granted the
fact that countries are a thing and that
i was born in pakistan that gives me a
pakistani passport my mom then moved us
to lesotho in southern africa worked
there for some some amount of time then
like right educational opportunities are
better in the uk let's move over to the
uk she had to sort out herself out with
a visa as a medic take the exams all
that crap come into the uk we lived here
for 10 years therefore we got a passport
and now i have a uk passport which means
it's so easy to travel anywhere in the
world except the us because of various
visa restrictions i have going to the us
in particular um but it's just sort of a
given that this is a thing and i've got
friends you know friends friends from
university who were international
students from pakistan and from other
places for whom it's like hey should we
take a trip to paris this weekend oh
sauz is going to take me eight weeks to
get a visa and who are kind of tied into
jobs that they don't necessarily enjoy
for five years at a time because well i
need to get my
indefinitely to remain my residency
permit and all that all this kind of
stuff which
is just
i had assumed was oh yeah that's just
that's just the way things have to work
because like countries and stuff
but
it sounds like
what
you're saying is that
the function of a country
is
you i if we think of a nation state or a
country as a product you are paying a
subscription fee to use the product
i.e tax and stuff or basically tax and
in return you are allowed to you then
have the privilege of being in the
country firstly you have a privilege of
working in the country and you get
access to amenities like health care
like in the uk
or um i don't know job seekers allowance
or these other sort of social safety
netty type things
and there's no reason why
that has to be confined to the country
that you were born in
what if we had a global safety wing of
like i pay my monthly subscription to
this to the overlords at safety wing or
whatever the process ends up looking
like and then
in return this
private corporation supplies me with
health care and pensions and
a social safety net if i lose my job and
stuff
does that sound about right what am i
missing
no that's a pretty good summary i think
there's a bunch of different things to
unpack there though um
the first thing
i'll talk about is just nation states
right so i've been very familiar with
this term for a long time because i
studied politics at university um i
guess they don't tell you about the
nation states at medical schools no it
wasn't just not a thing that came up
we just call them countries
so tldr just on nation state country
kind of concept it originates in 1648 in
west failure which i believe is in
germany and it was basically a bunch of
dudes getting together and like how will
we govern the people and they came up
with this idea of the nation's
how will we govern as in like because
before this it was like empires and
stuff yeah so or like uh sort of
regional powers and things but basically
like i guess my point here is just to
say that like the idea of a nation state
is actually so much newer than we think
okay so it we think about it as like oh
it's like since the beginning of
humanity surely yeah sorry the uk was a
thing and like surely like france was
the thing um
like 1066 battle of hasting
whatever from normandy invades england
like norman like
normandy was a place and england for the
country like
yeah how can we say that nation's days
didn't exist before 1648. because
literally the unit of nation state
didn't exist so um
what's the difference between a nation
state and a country
uh
well this is a kind of fundamental
question with regard to our internet
country but okay uh
essentially in the world today there's
not a lot of difference between a
country and a nation-state but the the
kind of plumeia product the entire idea
is to try and redefine what a country
can be i.e
it doesn't have to be this kind of thing
with a government and borders
and particular rules and kind of all of
this infrastructure
actually uh it can be something more
akin to like citizenship as a service
right so exactly as you were saying kind
of paying in for a membership whether
that's like a flat fee thing or it's a
percentage of income we don't have the
details on that stuff yeah looking sort
of at the 10-year horizon to be thinking
about some of that
um but fundamentally that's like the
idea that we are pursuing at safety wing
and at plumia is like how do you how do
you redesign a country for the 21st
century um and we tend to think that
countries are these things that are
completely fixed and you know we can't
really question them but actually like
within our lifetimes countries have
appeared and disappeared and failed
there are people today who were born in
a country that no longer exists because
that country has kind of changed its
name um so all of this is so much more
fluid than we tend to think from like a
kind of traditional um reading of the
situation i guess um
so i think that's all really interesting
there's one final thing i do want to
touch on from what you were talking
about though and that is this idea of
passport power right let's say you
mentioned that your um your friends from
uni some of them really kind of
struggled and would have to wait weeks
and weeks for visas this is
fundamentally one of the things that we
are trying to solve at safety wing so
our fundamental belief is that uh your
passport and your ability to kind of
move around the world should be based on
who you are not the kind of coincidence
of where you were born okay um and at
the moment we're in a situation in the
world where
a person's birthplace and or heritage
because there are different ways you can
kind of get a passport completely
defines their opportunities you know if
you are if you were born in eritrea you
do not have the same opportunities as
somebody born in the uk or france um
because you will be restricted and
exactly this way you were talking about
with like pakistani passports from
moving around the world
based literally only on your birthplace
or heritage
and
at the moment we're in this kind of zone
where there's a bit of a re-kind of
shuffling a re-reimagining of
some of that through nomad visas which
is something i talk about quite a bit in
the book
and essentially
nomad visas are something that came up
in response to the pandemic and the rise
of remote work um when countries kind of
tourism was devastated by the pandemic
and border closures and such they
started to invite digital nomads instead
and said hey come for three months come
for six months come for a year
and see how you like this place
and the kind of thing that changed that
i find really interesting there is that
they are much more interested in your
income and profession you're meeting
certain requirements in that respect
than necessarily your country of origin
the passport that you hold and i think
that's a really like positive signal
but it needs to be taken further there
are like a lot of kind of issues with
like nomad visas and how they've been
constructed some of them have not been
very successful um because they were
sort of created without any input from
end users and just kind of like thrown
out there into the world some
governments announced visa programs
without actually giving a date that
somebody might apply for that visa so
it's been a fairly messy kind of
landscape um but the general the general
move from an emphasis on birthplace to
income and profession i think is a
really good intermediary step to getting
towards
a more kind of
equality of opportunity globally so
wherever you are
in the future we want it to be like
wherever you were born you could access
another passport and be allowed to move
around the world the kind of interim
step we find ourselves in now is where
it's more based on kind of income and
profession which is not perfect but i
think is an improvement on birthplace
because
if you
you have more control over your income
and profession and can kind of work at
that whereas where you were born is
completely uh you know you can't do
anything about that like you don't have
any choice about that
okay so we're trying to build
an internet country
where you can sign up to the country
that will give you a passport that will
allow you to travel to other countries
and work in other countries and do all
those things that you can pay a
subscription fee i.e tax of some
description which will give you health
care and the other things that like
traditionally a country or a country's
government would in theory be providing
for you
um
one thing that like
last time last time we had dinner you
were kind of explaining this to me and i
just i didn't quite
i just had didn't have a way to
understand it at the time was
you it's it seems like you're keen on
like open borders for all kind of vibe
uh correct me if i'm wrong at that front
does that not mean that like the
quote more desirable places to live
would then become quote overrun with
everyone in the world wanting to flock
to that place and then the place becomes
less good
i think i think it's a really valid
question um but i guess my counter is
like there's um
there's a perception that if
all borders were kind of close like
gotten rid of not closed
um if all borders were kind of like um
destroyed tomorrow
you can go anywhere you want the general
perception is
well everybody from the global south
would want to come to like the uk or to
europe or to the united states um and
that's kind of like our assumption
but
interestingly like digital nomads are
doing the reverse of that in general
they're coming from like the most
powerful countries and the sort of most
expensive cities in the global north and
they are traveling to places in the
global south
and i think that
there's not really uh
i mean for one thing i suppose i should
say like really frankly it's like i'm
not advocating for borders to be like
completely abolished completely
abolished uh you know anytime soon i
think that that is the kind of utopian
vision we should be going toward as in
uh as everything becomes more borderless
like work finance uh knowledge like all
of these different things as that
becomes more borderless borders become
less relevant and more restrictive
for pointless reasons right and you
cannot go places because of borders but
i am also very very um i acknowledge and
appreciate that you can't just kind of
like move from where we are at the
moment to that so that's kind of the
utopian like vision to aim for at the
end of the day
um but in the interim i think it's much
more
i think there are a lot of benefits to
not necessarily getting rid of borders
but just making borders much more fluid
for people to move
move through and kind of move between i
don't i don't worry that uh more kind of
borderless
infrastructure or norms would lead to uh
most of the world moving to somewhere
else uh in a like unbalanced way i think
there are still a vast majority of
people in the world today that uh do
want like a home base and do want to
settle down and don't necessarily want
to move countries at all because they
like the culture and the weather where
they are um and so i think that's like
important to kind of realize but
it's also that um
people are moving all the time anyway
you know people like your family my
family have moved to places for economic
opportunity
to sort of escape like problematic kind
of situations whether they are like
political um or whatever
and
that is you know that's something that
that can't can't be stopped that's
happened throughout history like way
back like uh when humanity was like
doing agriculture and kind of moving
around the world everybody is always
kind of moving for some kind of new
opportunity whether that's economic or
love or whatever all the reasons that
people kind of move to different
countries um and i guess my vision like
what i want to happen is for that to
just become easier i don't think people
should
make decisions about their lives based
on the restrictions that they face from
the government they they're stuck with
right like i think they should be able
to go
i
really like this person that i've been
dating for three months and so i'm gonna
go and spend the next six months
in their country and in their city to
explore that and for it to not be like
and therefore i have to move my tax
residency get the correct visa
potentially start a company in that
jurisdiction if i'm a freelancer to
employ myself there's like all this kind
of friction and tension
for you to literally just be able to
have the freedom to be like i'm just
gonna go see if it works out with this
girl yeah right and that's kind of my
that's why i'm interested in open
borders or kind of getting rid of
borders it's much less in that sense of
like
them not existing and much more in that
sense of like individual people should
not be restricted
by essentially like a powerful kind of
government hand
sort of saying how people should live
their lives interesting
um
okay
coming back a little bit to some of the
digital nomadic bits um one thing that
tim ferriss highly advocated for in the
four hour work week was this idea of
outsourcing to
the global south broadly where
salaries are a lot lower
the
daily wage for someone in the
philippines might be five dollars a day
and so if you can pay that some five
dollars an hour then suddenly they're
doing super well by filipino standards
but you're also saving a lot of money
compared to hiring someone in the bay
area who might charge 500 an hour for
basically the same thing what's what's
the deal with that like tim ferriss like
some some people seem to seem to be like
very pro this some people seem to be
very anti this what's uh what's going on
there
okay so
so i think in principle um there is
nothing wrong it can even be net
positive to hire across borders right
particularly if you're able to connect
with people
uh for whom uh the money is very
meaningful so the example that you kind
of give if somebody is in the
philippines and even if they're not kind
of earning like a global wage for what
they're doing they may be earning double
triple quadruple even more than the
local wage they could get through a
non-kind of tech job if you like as in a
non-remote job and so i think broadly
that is positive however
you also kind of have to acknowledge
that by doing that you are kind of like
taking advantage of a global system yes
that's built on unfairness and
inequality because kind of going back to
what i was saying before about passports
and such it's like nobody can help where
they're born which passport they hold
and thus if that person in the
philippines is able to do the same job
as like a silicon valley developer you
then have some really big kind of like
ethical questions about well just
because it saves my business money
should i be paying this person
half a quarter of what i would pay for
somebody in the san francisco bay area
and so
i think it's
very much like uh
i think it's something that we kind of
all have to operate um
kind of as we're as we're doing things
we all have to kind of have this in mind
right we have to have it in mind that
there is
we're all kind of operating in the
system this global system which really
is quite unfair and unjust and it
encourages inequality between equally
skilled and talented people in different
jurisdictions
and i think that having an awareness of
that with any decision you make in a
business is just kind of
the definition of kind of the culture
that you're pursuing and what you build
right
um
but it's also bigger than that right
it's like if you if you want to hire
someone from the philippines or
somewhere else
you don't have control over whether that
person is actually allowed to come to
london and live here in order to do the
job sometimes that can be really
challenging and really really expensive
like for a company if somebody wants to
move like maybe the uh maybe like a kind
of moving is gonna increase the cost of
that person as in like their salary but
it's also going to cost a lot and take a
long time to actually sort out the
paperwork to make that possible right
and so part of the the kind of mission
that we're working on at premier in
safety wing
is to try and
create global mobility instruments and
kind of campaign
for
uh more kind of equality in this respect
of being able to actually move to places
easily and quite cheaply
to be able to do your work from anywhere
so to bring that a little bit more down
to reality um
right now there's a really big
fundamental issue with like the us in
particular right
even though we're in a world of remote
work now and somebody from anywhere in
the world could do the job that a us
company wants done remotely
right now you generally already have to
have a us green card in order to even
apply
for those positions
and so
the reason for that is because companies
don't want the hassle of having to sort
out these visas for people actually like
enabling them to kind of come
and work there if they don't already
have that entitlement but obviously that
means that any one company uh is missing
out on most of the world's talent they
can't kind of hire in the same way
it ends up for the people on the kind of
receiving end of that situation that um
they may be doing exactly the same job
but being paid a fraction of the price
and they're not able to kind of move
around the world because the the
immigration system is essentially like
very against them
um and so yeah i think that
it's all very connected it's kind of
like businesses and entrepreneurs can
only really make decisions on the basis
of that company the the company that
they're running and the kind of culture
that they want to champion
in what they do
i think there's this kind of other bit
that's really important that is about
policy and is about like what an
individual can do in the world
not what they have to rely upon like a
company or government to kind of give
them the right to do
um so yeah it's it's all kind of
reducing friction to try and create
equality of opportunity you know um
i don't believe that everybody should be
like communist level equal in terms of
like we should redistribute wealth and
and kind of like make everyone super
equal but i do fundamentally believe
that like you should have an equality of
opportunity wherever you're born in the
world that you can do what you want to
do in terms of you can move to a
different country you can try out
different types of work you can fall in
love across borders and it's not going
to be atrociously expensive and a load
of heartbreak there's nothing to do with
a relationship
damn yeah yeah i guess it's a lot so
yeah i i've not really thought of it in
in those terms before that
you know this micro decision of
do i hire someone in a different country
in a way actually i guess i guess we're
all making those market decisions like
when i buy anything from any company
that's made in any country in the world
other than the uk and even if it's made
in the uk if it's made up north it's
going to be cheaper than if it's made
down south it's like there's all of
these like inequalities and like
unfairnesses in the system um
you know i i think it's that quote you
know the the there is no ethical
consumption under capitalism or
something like that where there is
always going to be someone who's getting
screwed over in the process for for my
starbucks coffee that i had this morning
to get into my into my hands and
in a way
as individuals there's
i guess there's not much we can do about
it given that it's a global system
with so much like that's so deeply
entrenched that as an individual there's
not much you can do but i guess as
individuals there is at the same time
stuff we can do in terms of shifting our
consumption and maybe for example
companies
run by individuals choosing to actively
pay people location independent salaries
even though they don't have to just
because it's like well we're this is the
sort of culture that we'd like to create
is that fair to say
yeah i think so i do think that
individual choices matter in the sense
of like
if you're in a position of being able to
make like hiring decisions it is a good
thing to kind of have this in the back
of your mind and be able to be like
okay so what does it look like like what
does the kind of structure look like for
this person who's maybe doing some
freelance work for me from the
philippines to actually within a period
of time do more work for the company do
more work for me
and then actually to uh maybe come on as
a full-time team member
um at a sort of location independent
like rate of pay that's uh that's kind
of fair on that global scale not on that
kind of local scale
on a personal level like when i'm
working with freelancers uh if i'm
working with someone via a platform like
upwork uh for you know like really
little bits and pieces like ghosts um
like ghost you know cms type uh editing
and stuff that takes me forever
um if i'm just doing like a few hours of
work with someone and it's very much
that kind of like almost gig task based
thing
um
you know it's not a case of
me stopping to think for a very long
time about whether i should be paying a
silicon valley wage for that like three
hours of work because fundamentally like
uh it just needs to be frictionless and
i need the thing done right
but if that person begins doing like 10
or 20 hours per month of work for me and
i'm like okay so this person's really
great i think they'd be a good cultural
fit
then i will try and kind of like bring
them
off of a platform and and more kind of
into like our general pool
um i think it's really tough because if
you're testing out new people a lot of
the time that's you know like people
aren't always up to the job so it's hard
to kind of like from a total starting
point be like
i'm gonna pay everybody the same i'm
gonna make sure that like i'm paying
like london rates not filipino rates or
whatever however i think that when you
are a decision maker and you're kind of
going through that process and you're
kind of getting to know talented people
you have to have that awareness that
it's like well i could just put them on
what's a good annual salary for them and
their location
or i could go this person is clearly
talented and dedicated thus i i'm gonna
like put them on the same as my person
who's sitting in london with me uh who's
doing a similar job
[Music]
yeah um i was talking about this with
the with one of my friends when we were
you know just
discussing this idea of like the the
ethics of outsourcing and came this
whole thing of like oh this is one of
the critiques of globalization i was
like oh yeah i last heard that word in
like gcc geography but have not thought
about it ever since then and then i
picked up this but you know the
very short guide to very short
introduction to globalization and the
globalization paradigms like oh people
have been thinking about these issues
like these are not it's not just a an
isolated thing
um and apparently there's this thing in
in philosophy uh like the the paradox of
exploitation
um which is this idea that
uh essentially
how you feel ethically about situations
like should i hire someone from the
philippines et cetera et cetera depends
on one fundamental question and the
fundamental question is if a transaction
is mutually consensual
but unfair should the transaction take
place
and if you think that well both parties
are consenting even if one party is
being shortchanged and this as long as
they're consenting it's all good we
believe in individual consent then the
answer is of course yes it should like
the person in the philippines is happy
to be paid the wage
the company in the u.s who's hiring them
is more than happy to give them the wage
both parties are consenting therefore
this is ethical even if it's unfair and
the other side of the coin is like well
if you think a transaction between two
mutually consenting parties that is
unfair should not happen at that point
you're like well even though they're
consenting
there's still something ethically wrong
with this and i guess some of those
people would say therefore the
kind of the invisible hand of the
government or whatever should stop that
transaction from taking place
and
there's uh you know apparent apparently
there's been a paradox in philosophy for
absolutely ages but there's this paper
by some
philosophy professor at like ucl or
something where it's like actually
the the there's a fairly easy solution
to the problem and that solution is that
um when you hire someone
as a company you then have a duty of
care to that person and that duty of
chao means you should treat them in a
nice way which i guess is a very it's
sort of i don't know to me that made a
lot of sense because i was like oh okay
cool that like
allows me allows one plus one e to equal
two without having to hold these two
fundamentally opposing things of like i
think this is unfair but also they're
agreeing to it
but i think it's unfair and like if i
didn't hire them then they'd be worse
off worse off and i'd be worse off let's
stop fundamentally unfair and all these
all these other issues like well if i do
hire someone i have a duty of care to
them and
as a good person as wanting to create a
certain culture within my team and my
company it is only fair that i pay them
a certain
you know a certain way probably a
location independent
but then you know
you know i was talking about
searching through a bunch of tweets
about this kind of stuff obviously the
bad place to find nuanced information
but you know just this idea that when i
go visit you know i'm going i'm going to
turkey next week for example and if i
buy food i'm not going to pay double the
price because that's
you know the purchasing price disparity
between the currency of turkey versus
the currency of the uk so like
you know what's
what about like purchasing decisions
would someone would it be ethical for
someone to voluntarily pay like you know
when i buy a seven up in pakistan i'm
actually going to pay 20 times the price
because this is what i would have paid
for it when i was in london any any
thoughts on the
that thing
yeah i don't think that people should go
around the world paying more than the
actual price for things like i mean i
make a point of tipping um just wherever
i go particularly in places where
there's a tipping culture because
obviously it's very rude not to not to
tip in those but um even in places where
there aren't like i'll try and tip if
it's good service if it's a good thing
um but no i don't really feel any
pressure around that at all i think i
relate a lot to what you said about kind
of having that duty of care over
somebody who's uh working for your
company or who you're collaborating with
on things um
and actually i think that you know so
much in life um and i think you and i
probably share this philosophy but like
comes down to human relationships and
like how you build those relationships
right and like i think you and i are
probably both the kind of people who see
people as humans not as numbers so
you know it is kind of about that i
think on an individual level making
those decisions in ways that kind of
resonate with your own like personal
human values
um
i do think that uh a fundamental problem
for a lot of a lot of folks is that
they're working with companies or
they're working with people who actually
aren't open to dialogue on things um and
actually like this is a problem even
like within the uk context like i have
friends who just don't feel like they
can ask for like a pay rise like that
that's that's not a conversation that
that is there that they feel comfortable
kind of like having with a manager or a
boss
um and so yeah i think that
if you can focus on individual humans
that's probably the best way to navigate
without it becoming unmanageable to
actually kind of make those decisions on
a day-to-day basis yeah
yeah so i guess like
bringing this this thing around ethics
back to the digital nomadic stuff one
thing i've heard is that uh digital
nomadism is the new colonialism
what's the what's going on there like
why do some people hate hate on the
digital nomad thing for that on on those
grounds
yeah so i mean i i suppose a good
example of this um would probably be uh
mexico right i'm just back for a couple
of uh from a couple of months in mexico
and i was very surprised to learn that
there's a huge backlash going on against
digital nomads there
uh and there are a few different reasons
for that one is just that the mexican
government has had incredibly lacked
border controls through the whole
pandemic so whenever else pretty much
was closed
mexico oh yeah all my friends are going
on holiday to mexico yeah yeah
and so obviously digital nomads went
there and there's relatively like simple
routes to residency in mexico and then
there are like a bunch of like kind of
added benefits to
to how that all works as and you can
quite easily as a foreigner come and end
up living in mexico if you have enough
money that's kind of the bottom line
right
but there's this huge backlash because
uh there's a lot of gentrification
happening particularly in mexico city
and over in tulum and playa.com and
these kind of like more beachy
destinations um and these have become
like real nomad hotspots at the same
time as the same kind of gentrification
that people talk about in like london or
new york is also happening in those
places
um
and so the the kind of backlash comes
not necessarily
from
people being
nomads but more the kind of like
inequality of the situation if you think
specifically about american nomads going
and basing themselves in mexico and
living the life of a king compared to
new york or san francisco because their
money stretches further you then think
about how mexicans are treated at the
u.s border i was literally in line
behind somebody with a mexican passport
when i passed into
into the us on my way back
from from mexico and like they were
questioned like so much more heavily
they were really kind of like given a
grilling
even though they were just there for
like a week's holiday and i think that
that is something that's really kind of
reflected in this backlash against
digital nomads is like
how can you like how can you come here
and make life worse for people here
at the same time as treating like people
from this place extremely badly when
they try and kind of enter yeah and come
to to the us and so again this is kind
of this global mobility kind of
inequality thing that i've talked about
um a couple of times in this
conversation
and
you know i i've written um about kind of
like digital nomads and colonialism and
the comparisons kind of between them
i don't find it uh
i don't think it's the it's the same uh
in any sense like nomads are not
necessarily like going to places to kind
of exploit them and take the kind of
natural resources and kind of ship them
back home and kind of make all the all
the profits uh in a different country
but then there is also a valid kind of
like uh criticism which is like if
there's a digital nomad living in
country x and they're not actually
paying income taxes in country x
then they kind of are sending their
profits back to the homeland if you like
which i guess is kind of a valid
comparison
but that really comes down to the fact
that the global tax system can't cope
with remote work so like there's not a
way
to essentially pay taxes
on the ground where you are most digital
nomads would be quite happy to pay into
a system uh that was specific for them
like okay so you're coming and you're
remote working here for three months and
first we'd like you to pay this amount
of taxes um
and you kind of see some precedence with
that like with um
uh
tourist taxes yeah that's the thing in
paris and absolutely like two pounds
something for the night or something
something to that effect yeah and but i
mean most of those things are kind of
collected through accommodation
providers so it's like that kind of
infrastructure exists
uh something we're
interested in kind of working on as we
develop this uh nomad border pass at
safety wing and plumia is actually tax
functionality so the nomads would be
able to kind of like pay into that local
economy that they are spending time
in a way that is as seamless as like an
oyster card on the tube yeah and we're
really looking to remove as much
friction as possible from all these kind
of different areas
and sort of just i guess give new
options for people like to actually kind
of pay in and create kind of more
uh more of a relationship there okay
yeah and i guess kind of individual
governments who maybe have like a four
or five year tenure are
maybe more concerned with short-term
short-term cash of like oh cool these
rich people are coming into the country
let's build
housing that is like super expensive so
that we make more money on tax or
whatever and
sort of oh that that means when next
election round comes around we'll we'll
be able to say we've increased gdp by x
rather than thinking of like the 20-year
downstream consequences of said housing
project
totally um i think
a lack of vision and a lack of long-term
thinking and policy is like one of the
fundamental problems with our current
like political systems like the if you
think of everything in life and in the
world as like incentives right like what
are the incentives in the game like the
incentives in the system
right now if you are in traditional
politics your incentives are to make
five-year decisions or whatever you know
the number of years after a particular
context but are to make five-year
decisions
um and then to win the next election and
actually uh two and a half years into
your five-year term you have to start
thinking about the next election so like
really you're you're not very concerned
with what's happening during that five
years compared to making sure that you
get another five years but it's kind of
a lack of space for
long-term thinking
i think a place like singapore is a
really interesting example of a country
that is really really committed to
long-term thinking um you see it you see
quite a lot of good stuff happening uh
in a lot of european governments as well
where it's just like
i don't know one of the things that i
notice is the stronger kind of regional
or city authorities are yeah
the more
stable the kind of long-term strategy
the long-term thinking of place is
um and i think that's just because
there's
you know there's a really great ted talk
uh maybe we can like link it on the
video or something called um why mares
should rule the world and it just kind
of talks about like you know the power
of politicians who are
in close physical proximity to you i if
you're a man you can walk you have to be
able to walk around your city and people
have to be happy enough with you that
they're not going to throw like rotten
vegetables at you
whereas like national politicians can be
incredibly incredibly detached uh to the
extent that like you will never see them
in person
and i think that kind of creates like uh
not great incentives for
actually doing stuff that is going to
please voters as opposed to
be good in the media or be good on
social media when you kind of promote it
yeah i think if we could if we could get
more long-term thinking happening with
policy all over the world that would be
a real victory
um but maybe just to kind of add
actually i mean something interesting
say safety wing are committed to funding
plumia the kind of internet country
development the development of that
vision
um for the next 10 years so i'm in this
privileged position in the role that i'm
in where i can think at least double the
length of any traditional politician um
and i find that really kind of exciting
to be able to think about infrastructure
kind of in that same way that
politicians or governments are meant to
yeah but actually without any of the the
kind of party politics and the kind of
uh electoral aspects of it which i think
can be quite like draining for everybody
involved aren't really creating much
value
yeah it almost feels like um being a
being tenured at a university gives you
the privilege and permissioned to have
long term to think long term cause
you're like cool i've got this i don't
need to worry for a while so now what
are the cool thing cool interesting
projects i can do
but coming back to this point about
long-term planning i mean i suppose
someone
if we think of places that have good
long-term planning singapore had a
long-term plan uh dubai famously had a
very good long-term plan and the people
of dubai apparently love the
people in charge of like bloody hell
this plan really worked out nicely but
if you think of singapore and dubai as
being like you know they're not really
models for democracy so
how
in
in your mind i mean i'm sure there's not
an easy answer to this but how does
democracy the idea of democracy square
with the idea of like it would be cool
to have long-term planning rather than
incentivization happening as a result of
democratic
yeah so i think on the kind of long-term
horizon i see
the kind of uh i guess representation or
more democratic aspect falling a lot
more to local and regional authorities i
like uh if you think about at the moment
we have like the local layer the
national layer and the global layer
right
uh i think the national layer is on its
way out if you're thinking about 10 20
years down the line it's becoming less
and less relevant to the way that we
live our lives that kind of lives you
leaves you with the the global layer and
the local language local meaning city
states
so it's meaning regions or cities right
um so just as an example like um if
you're talking about like the uk uh you
might talk about like norwich as the
city but norfolk as kind of the region
in the us you might uh talk about like
the kind of federal state system i.e the
state of x as opposed to just one city
but these things kind of play out
differently and in different parts of
the world
in terms of how how everything is
structured um
but yeah i think that um
i think that that kind of the the kind
of voting and elections and democracy is
definitely super super important at that
local level
i think at the global layer and the way
that we're kind of envisioning things
like citizenship as a service like an
opt-in membership in which you have very
plainly stated this is what we're
providing this is how it works
it's really unclear to me at the moment
like
how and when uh and under what
circumstances uh we would introduce kind
of a democratic structure to govern that
um
because it's kind of like when it's
opt-in it's like
if you wanna if you wanna be part of
this great like be be a citizen of our
country yeah um but if you don't wanna
be part of it like nobody is forcing you
to
um i think i see the challenge thinking
long term on it like as more like um
compa like companies and kind of like
unions or whatever so like as in the the
relationship between
it's not even necessarily unions that
might be a bad example
i see it as kind of um
the relationship between the internet
country and its users will need a lot of
attention paid to it and we're really
committed a kind of safety wearing
philosophy is to be very user focused so
to focus on what people like and don't
like about what you're doing and keep
optimizing so we want to kind of take
that approach so it's definitely not a
case of like
we're building a thing yes and we're not
going to listen to any user of it or
anybody and that's just what it is but
it's also not that uh we are going to
introduce kind of like a liquid
democracy like direct voting system as a
first step
um i think in my mind it's really really
important to actually build a thing
worth being part of
before kind of getting too stuck into
these really really age-old tough
questions over how to make decisions how
technology can enable that um i'm really
resistant to the idea of like
essentially uploading like the whole
like party political system and
elections and voting up to the like up
to the cloud and kind of have that be
like front and center of an internet
country because
i don't i don't think it's a productive
good system i don't think it's effective
i think that you end up paying a lot of
pr companies and getting a lot of media
coverage and kind of doing all these
things
like to kind of show face instead of
actually creating value
and so yeah i don't know like how it
will work out long term and we're
certainly very open-minded like there's
a lot of discussions go on kind of our
community and in our team
about
i guess like the the outcomes and the
equity in a situation of like okay
you know how can we how can we kind of
receive feedback but actually make sure
that that feedback is actioned and
actually if you're doing everybody votes
directly on everything all the time it
becomes really difficult to actually
like do anything about that other than
be like and this is what the people said
yes um so yeah when i when i did my kind
of uh
crappy explanation of nation states and
stuff kind of this idea of
sort of safety wing or plume or whatever
the internet country is in a way being a
global overlord where in a in a way you
know read uncharitably
there's a bit of a dystopian vibe to it
of like oh there is this private
corporation that is now in charge of
your passport and that's in charge of
your health care and you have to pay a
subscription to it and they can up up
the subscription subscription whenever
they want etcetera etcetera oh how are
you guys thinking about kind of that
that narrative yeah i mean we're
definitely like as a group of people
having come together to try and create
something we're definitely more utopian
than dystopian but i also totally take
like the kind of um criticism of how
that can seem
i think that probably one of the
parallels to draw to kind of understand
the context in which we're working is
that tech companies already hold a huge
amount of power over all of us and a
huge amount of information i think
there's some really interesting kind of
like user versus company kind of like
dynamics there right so like
i mean you have it within workforces as
well to use google as an example like um
uh there were a bunch of people walked
out because they didn't want the company
uh doing military tech like for the us
government and you also have users who
will like mass exodus from a platform
based on kind of uh its ethics or
performance or whatever
um and so yeah i think that you know you
can't ignore that actually some of the
biggest competitors to traditional
nation states
are in fact uh tech companies
not countries like not not kind of
traditional countries and so that's kind
of the space that um that we're
operating in at the moment i do think
that a lot can be
a lot can be achieved by designing the
system well and designing the kind of
feedback loops well to make sure that
the thing is developing in the direction
that its users want it to develop
um there's some really interesting work
going on at the moment that um i kind of
want to look more into as well um
around uh exit to community have you
come across this what's that
so it's kind of this movement um among
particularly like open source software
um or like the kind of open source
ecosystem um a bit more broadly than
that but it's this idea that um rather
than kind of exiting to ipo or exiting
to investors in the future there could
be structures for uh companies tech
companies to actually kind of exit to
their community i.e to hand ownership of
a thing over to the people using it
i'm very interested in that there's a
lot of really kind of um accomplished
people kind of exploring in that area
right now but it's very very early stage
um as in like there aren't those
structures there's not like a kind of
road map of how we get from here to
there but i'm interested in the
potential of a lot of these kind of
ideas that are going around the
ecosystem uh of kind of tech
to kind of re-imagine like what things
could be i also think that um there's a
huge kind of thing here uh to to flag
and i don't want to make this a crypto
conversation because i try to avoid them
in general but uh i do think
cryptocurrency is having a really big
impact not just on economics but
actually on um
how people organize and how people work
and how people work in the future so at
the same time
sorry how so
uh so do you know about dals
yes ish
not really
so i guess tldr is um
[Music]
people are getting together so dao
stands for decentralized autonomous
organization
coders can build these things these sort
of uh algorithmic companies if you like
or organizations
and then they tend to have like a
cryptocurrency underpinning them like
either one of the big cryptocurrencies
or a very localized kind of currency um
to that kind of ecosystem
and then people can work for that dow
instead of engaging with the traditional
economy
and they tend to be flat hierarchies so
they are like people are working
together as a network on equal footing
rather than in that like bus manager
like a traditional employee kind of
sense and i think it's just really
relevant to to kind of note that that's
also going on because you can kind of
incorp you can kind of interpret
a lot of that
as almost a backlash or a different kind
of direction than big tech in the
silicon valley mold
um and so there are all these kind of
different ideas developing all the time
and i think it's really difficult to
kind of um
say any one thing without considering
all the different stuff that people are
working on within the ecosystem and the
new opportunities that that kind of uh
creates as you go on um we say a lot
like i think this is a quote from brian
eno um but we say a lot of plumia like
get cooking uh recipe to follow so as in
like get going start building something
even if you don't know like what you're
cooking yet you know get those onions
and that garlic into the pan they're
probably gonna be good and tasty and
useful whatever happens next nice i
guess one other thing that i was i was
thinking is this idea of an internet
country which you pay a subscription fee
for and return for amenities like
healthcare and stuff and xyz in a way
like if people don't like it a they
don't have to opt into it because it's
entirely optional but b i'm sure there
will there will be other competitors
that spring up so like with any kind of
product if i don't like notion i can
move to as a one of a zillion
note-taking apps and
nowadays
one of the big selling points in
note-taking apps like things like
obsidian is the fact that you own your
own data that you can always migrate to
another another app and you're not like
locked in so maybe there's a thing of
like
you know there's just my bro science
speaking but like in the future
an internet country project maybe it's
premium
maybe it's not would be like
hey you can actually leave us at any
point and you can transfer out like your
pension or your iso or your investment
account or whatever to whatever other
provider you want and we're not going to
stop you we're hoping that
by the by virtue of the fact that we are
good and we
serve the users and we're amazing you'll
continue to pay us similar to spotify
you can always move out to apple music
but you wouldn't want to because spotify
is just better
is that kind of what you guys are
thinking or am i am i off base no
totally i think um i think people call
that portability don't they yeah kind of
data portability um i think that's
really important and i think that will
be
a kind of natural part of what we do so
our kind of philosophy at safety wing is
uh we want to make products uh that are
so good you tell your friends about them
uh we like have a company policy of not
paying for direct advertising um because
we we don't believe that that's like the
the way necessarily to kind of like
build
a product and kind of like a
relationship with users that is
meaningful yeah um
and so yeah i think that um
i think that like uh portability is uh
just a kind of to me it's like a natural
thing like particularly if we're in a
competitive landscape of internet
countries uh i would personally as a
user want reassurances that i could kind
of like move that on uh or even
potentially for a while like move it
back to a traditional nation state if
you imagine a situation where you have a
plume of passport right
and uh you give up your british passport
let's say because the premier passport
is all good but then what happens if
after 10 years you don't approve of the
premier policies anymore you want to
kind of move on or even move back so as
in like you want to reclaim your british
passport
or you want to move on to another
internet country or maybe now you're
going to take a dutch passport or
something like that um i think what's
really interesting about all of this by
the way is just that like uh it's kind
of all very competitive right like as in
like country should be competing for
talented people and i think that's like
the kind of landscape that we're
entering into now is a situation where
it's not just internet countries
challenging people's current
citizenships
it's actually all countries realizing
that in a world of remote work
they can pinch all those people who
don't want to live in san francisco
their roles are remote and they can get
them to kind of come
and establish kind of a hub where they
are and so you see that a little bit you
know i mentioned bali before
um bali is um
a place that is a real kind of like
nomad hotspot a lot of companies have
been built out of bali now so like a
trend over the last 10 years was like
people would go to y combinator or like
entrepreneur first raise money and then
be like okay so i've got a runway it'll
last me like two years in san francisco
if i went to bali though it probably
lasts me more like ten years yeah
and sort of making these decisions but
smart governments are really kind of
like trying to leverage this now they're
going like okay who are we gonna target
yeah how are we gonna get them and what
is it that we can offer to them that's
going to attract them
so in the us in particular this has
really taken off already so you have a
whole bunch of like to be honest like
towns and regions you've probably never
heard of um that are offering lit
literal like cash grants for people to
relocate you already have to be an
american citizen for those programs but
you can get like ten or fifteen thousand
dollars uh
to to move to a place as a remote worker
now yeah um and i think this is
fascinating uh and i think we will see
so much competition for people and that
this hopefully will also raise standards
so not only for premiere and kind of
internet countries but actually for
existing countries um if you're in a
situation where like uh
let's say the plumia citizenship offers
pretty much all the same benefits as
british citizenship
maybe without the ability to vote right
because in like you don't there's not
democratic infrastructure because uh
it's citizenship as a service
would being able to vote in traditional
elections as they exist in the uk right
now actually be a meaningful feature you
know if you think about this as a tech
product like would this be a meaningful
feature for people to choose that a more
expensive less efficient option yes
versus an extremely streamlined
tech driven citizenship with plumia that
maybe you don't get the
say in in a traditional sense of like
electoral politics but you do get a say
in in the sense that like if you email
feedback.org
we are like going to listen to you and
kind of take into account yeah
email feedback
yeah i guess this is why people are
chill about moving to places like
singapore and dubai and stuff because
it's like i'll happily take the hit of
like
no democracy in return for
lower taxes better lifestyle safety all
of all of the other equip features that
a
city or a country could have
um and i guess just
thinking in those terms and like oh but
that actually is an option and
countries do now have to compete for
talent uh
just is i don't know it's just like a
cool way of thinking that
i guess we're not used to thinking of
because the idea of countries is so
entrenched in the way that we view the
world
for sure yeah
yeah i feel like this is a good a good
place to end this um
so practically speaking takeaways for me
are
um this
nomadi stuff seems cool uh i guess i was
kind of like oh i need to have a whole
year where i'm just traveling to be able
to take advantage of it but actually
spending a month at hacker's paradise or
equivalent um you know we had that deal
with with zoku you know this idea of
traveling to different um
different cool places and co-working
from there before covert completely
screwed that up but it's something like
that that you know actually we've got a
few team members who have been trying to
talk into moving into moving to london
they're a bit like oh you know i live i
live in northampton and like life in
northampton's a bit boring it's like
we'll move to london oh but it's it's
expensive and i'm not sure if i'll like
it like just try that for a month just
getting airbnb it's so easy to to give
that advice to other people whereas for
myself i'm like oh i couldn't possibly
travel unless i've got a whole year
unless i've really thought this out like
it's probably not that hard to try out
the nomad lifestyle and see what it's
like
um
and i remember there was this uh this
blog post from tim ferriss that i read
re-read recently where he talks about
this lawyer guy who freaking hated his
job in law decided on a whim that he was
going to move to i think maybe it was
mexico or something and
realized he had actually great life
there became like a surf instructor and
it kind of ends with him
speaking to another lawyer who's like oh
my god i wish i could have this kind of
lifestyle and the guy's just like well
you kind of can it's just that you're
the way you're thinking about your life
is
so kind of entrenched in
uh the traditional idea of what success
means
in like a job in like a big city with a
high salary with high cost of rent et
cetera et cetera
that just it just takes a little bit of
a push to start thinking beyond those
terms
yeah i think um
a lot of people have this kind of
inbuilt fear of really going after what
makes them happy and i think that my
experiences with digital nomads around
the world is like the polar opposite of
that like you speak to a nomad and
they're like
what makes me happy
is like
having an ikea desk uh in a place and a
computer and i do my work and then i
like to go to the gym and then i like to
go and do this and go and do that
they're incredibly sure
as am i like about what it is that
they're looking for from life and also
from travels as in like you know i give
that example of like you know an ikea
desk and a monitor or whatever because
uh i know a lot of people who literally
like buy the same ikea desk wherever
they go so if they're in four or five
different countries for like two or
three months at a time
they will literally just order the same
thing they know how to put it together
because they've had it before and just
kind of set that up in their airbnb
apartment
um and then they have what they need for
work and they're very sure about that
they've optimized that they travel with
the bit that they need they know what
they need to buy on the ground um
i know some people are really into
surfing some people are really into
beaches some people are really into
cities um but i think just in general
that kind of i think i referred to it
before like the personal growth that you
kind of go through by traveling and also
just the kind of like self-reflection
that you have to do to make a nomadic
lifestyle work when you go like okay
will it make me happy to to kind of like
go to this place and experience all of
this
um and like what is it that i need to
feel grounded if i'm not at home in that
traditional sense like you just kind of
get to know yourself so much better and
you're able to
yeah really kind of go after what makes
you happy like there's so many folks i
know who are like
yeah i'm a digital nomad but like i'm
like regimented in my routine and i'm
kind of boring you know and like it's
very very individual i think like how
you perceive things and exactly what you
pursue yeah and i guess one of the cool
things about being a digital nomad and
doing this traveling thing is that your
feedback loops are quite short in terms
of trying out different lifestyles and
seeing what you like whereas
following like if i think of all my
friends who are still in medicine um you
know
left school at 18 having decided to do
medicine at the age of 14 optimized or
optimized the hell out of the cv et
cetera et cetera stayed in medical
school for six years gone straight into
a job it's like one
life path
and
you know
the friends i have who you know after
two years of working as a foundation
doctor there's a natural career gap and
then people do all sorts of things and
they realize oh crap like there are
other ways of living um but usually
that's just for a year and it's like oh
but i still need to have good stuff on
my cv and it just sort of entrenches you
into a particular life path um but
actually one of the students on my
youtube academy i was speaking to
yesterday um you know trained as a
trained as a doctor in oxford and then
did like a surgeon surgery thing at
harvard and then worked at mckinsey for
a bit and then started his own startup
for a bit and is now a digital nomad
with a wife and three kids currently
living in cape town uh you know from
from the uk originally and
that just seemed seemed pretty cool um
around how having actually these
different life experiences because
hashtag yellow you only live once you
might as well kind of
figure out based on feedback loops what
is the thing you actually enjoy and then
you can start optimizing for that thing
so do you think in this conversation uh
i've convinced you to give nomadic a try
like is there gonna be a follow-up
conversation where we're in like
malaysia with some lights that fit in
your suitcase later this year yeah yeah
i think so i think that's the plan um we
kind of have been
figuring out what does the nomad travel
setup look like for me like right now
we've got this studio for the next like
six five six months
we're seriously thinking okay
you know when our one-year mark runs out
at the studio it's like super expensive
it's super nice the vibes are great but
is there a way that we can kind of pair
things down potentially
get like a house that has maybe three
bedrooms and one of them we turn into a
podcast studio one them to be turned
into in into a youtube kind of thing
but even that feels a bit like
restrictive in us in the sense that
like i really like working in working
with people in person i think that's a
thing that makes me really happy one of
the things that i realized that what i
do i don't really like working from home
having done it through throughout the
pandemic and when i started going to the
local wework i was like oh my god this
is
it's all about co-working spaces um
and so
i just i'm just trying to figure out
what does our company look like
bearing man i do like working with
people but i also like the idea of
having freedom and stuff to travel and i
also like the idea of not necessarily
having an expensive office space that
we're paying large amounts of rent for
any ideas on that front yeah definitely
so i think actually it's an important
point to make right that i i love
working with people in person like i
i think that it's not in fact maybe it's
not so much like always working with
people in person but it's like spending
time with people in person it's like
vastly superior to video calls etc um
and that's partially why i arrange my
travels so i can go see people um and
actually kind of like spend time with
them in person um i find the balance
that we have at safety wing really good
so a couple of times a year we get
together for a week or so like a whole
whole company retreat different place in
the world every time
so we were in mexico yeah and kind of
had like a get together there i think
there's another one kind of on the cards
for bali at some point but just kind of
having that
i guess quite concentrated in person
time and then having periods of kind of
like deeper work and where you are kind
of just keeping in touch more
using digital tools i find that balance
works really well and i actually have
incredibly strong friendships and
professional relationships with people
because i'm able to be extremely present
with them when i'm physically there but
i'm not always in the same place around
the same group of people so i think
there's like a natural um
it can be quite positive to kind of have
a natural break from people and miss
them and then kind of go and really be
very invested in being there i don't
know how much of that that's all quite
personal but i don't know how much of
that can kind of be applied to the
mindset of thinking about um how to do
the the company i have to say that it's
um if you actually do the numbers it's
generally like a lot cheaper and a lot
more fun to bring a whole team together
several times a year in far away kind of
paradise location obviously
uh than it is to maintain an office in
like one expensive city yeah so my
recommendation for you would definitely
be to kind of like just really think
outside the box for 2023 like how can
you like rather than being like what do
other companies do yeah it's more like
what does ali's company do like what am
i feeling like what's the vibe check
here yeah
great well thank you very much lauren um
final question uh i guess if anyone's
listened or watched this far in the
conversation they became keen to hear
more of your thoughts around this stuff
so what's what's the deal with your book
uh so my book is called global natives
and uh it's essentially about uh how
digital nomads are taking over the world
so it's not a how-to it won't teach you
how to be a digital nomad but it kind of
tackles this question of what if loads
more people become digital nomads like
what does the world look like then yeah
what other kind of some of the exciting
kind of like uh like lifestyle services
and business models uh that might be out
there and how does like policy need to
change uh so that we can kind of like
move around the world uh without all of
this friction that i've been talking
about um and i guess in a way if you
people are interested in the internet
country thing like global natives my
book is very much like the the precursor
to what we're doing at plumier so a lot
of the ideas in there a lot of the
problems that i identify and the
solutions that i kind of suggest
i'm now actually kind of able to put
those into practice uh through plumier
and safety wing
and there will be another book in the
future uh that's a bit more on the
internet country side of things um so
yeah i also love to tweet so come say hi
on twitter fantastic so links to the
book links to the newsletter links to
the twitter account links to all of your
stuff will be in the show notes in the
video description as usual uh thanks
very much for coming on this has been
great thanks for having me all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
gonna be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye